يشير الخبراء الى ان هناك استحاله باتخاذ
اجراء حاسم مع القوات البريه يمكن تعويضها
بهجوم مركز وقوي للغايه على منطقه معينه
وهي زبولوجيا الى اي مدى توافق على ذلك
ولن يكون لذلك خطر او يكون ذلك اكثر خطوره
خاصه انه كما تعلم هناك منشات نوويه في
هذه المنطقه وهي من اكبر واخطر المنشات في
العالم هذا معروف
ة بكونها مقرا لاضخم المنشاه النوويه في
اوروبا وتم قصفها واستهدافها ثم السيطره
عليها من قبل القوات الاتحاد الروسي في
بدايه الاحداث العام الماضي فان القلق
يساور الجميع بشانها بشان او بسبب احتمال
تسرب النووي كل ذلك لا يجعلني في نفس
الوقت اعتقد ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستركز
على منطقه محدده تعرفون ان هناك الكثير من
الحديث بشان الهجوم الاوكراني لكن تقديري
ان الامر لن يتعلق بهجوم اوكراني ولكن
بهجمات اوكرانيه سيهاجمون عده مناطق سواء
بكيفيه متزامنه اول واحده تلو الاخرى
مهمه نعم وسيكونون سعداء باستعادتها مع
منشاتها النوويه خاصه لكن ذلك سيحتوي على
مخاطره بان يتسبب بحادث نووي لن يخطط له
لاروس ولا الاوكرانيون ولكن عندما تطلق
الصواريخ عليك ان تستعد لاحتمال ان يصيب
احدها منشاه لم تخطط لاصابتها حتى لو كان
لديك اكثر انظمه الاستهداف دقه فالحوادث
ممكنه والاخطاء ترتكب والتكنولوجيا تتعطل
لذلك اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين والروس سيكونون
حذرين فيما يتعلق
فعندما جد حادث تشيرنوبيل كان هناك عامل
وحيد لم يستطع اي احد
التحكم به بما فيهم الولايات المتحده وهو
الرياح فحتى في غياب القصد فانا اثار
الحادث بلغت الكثير من الاتجاهات التي لم
تكن في الحسبان بسبب عدم القدره على
التحكم في سرعه الرياح واتجاهاتها وهذا قد
يحدث مع مولدات الطاقه النوويه في
زابوريجيا يمكن ان يتضرر احد المفاعلات
ومنه تتسرب الاشعاعات وقد نشهد انفجارات
نوويه ولا يمكنك ان تعرفي وجهه الريحه
التي يمكن ان تكون الاراضي الروسيه نفسها
لذلك سيكون هناك الكثير من الحذر بشانها